okay so the topic of this video is going
to be proper study habits and study
skills so let's get started imagine that
you're an athlete maybe lacrosse maybe
volleyball maybe baseball let's talk
about how you prepare for that sport so
let's examine this calendar here maybe
on the first is our first day of
baseball and then on the 17th is our
first game so in between you your coach
your teammates your meeting for practice
probably around 2 or 3 hours a day and
even on the weekends you're probably
doing practice on your own so come the
first game you can be sure of giving
your best effort maybe you're more into
the performing arts maybe you're a
drummer maybe you're in drama maybe
you're in the choir let's talk about how
you prepare for those so on our calendar
the first is our first day of Orchestra
and the 17th let's say is our concert
well in between your meeting you're
rehearsing probably for a couple hours a
day and you're probably even rehearsing
on the weekend so you can be sure of
giving your best performance okay now be
honest do we follow that same daily
pattern of practice and rehearsal when
it comes to our academics now when do
you normally begin to study for a test
let's pretend that Monday the first you
start a chapter and as the days go by
you learn more and more and more
material associated with that unit and
on the 10th the teacher might announce
in one week we're going to have a test
but then your teacher continues with the
daily lesson and eventually we come with
the seventeenth boom test a time for you
to show how much you've prepared and how
ready you are you know I've been a
teacher since 1999 and I've been
surveying students about when do they
choose to study for a test and here are
the top three answers the number one
most common answer is the day before the
test number two most common answer going
back to my surveys starting in 1999 two
days before the test and the third most
common
answer is the day of the test and these
are the habits I want to address in this
video imagine if we prepared for our
athletics like this
so in our baseball situation imagine if
in between the first and the sixteenth
were not doing any practice and we only
practice one day before the game
imagine how ill-prepared we would be for
that contest imagine if we prepared for
the performing arts like this so imagine
in our orchestra calendar knowing
there's a concert on the 17th if we
start rehearsing on the 16th imagine how
ill-prepared we would be for that
concert now most athletes and most
performing artists would never do this
but this is how many students are
choosing to prepare for their academics
and that's the problem I want to address
so by looking at our calendar here the
problem is by not spending some time
reviewing we're going to forget a lot of
material and even though we might study
some on the sixteenth trying to remember
two and a half weeks of information is
very difficult so does this method of
waiting one day before the test to study
work well in your early school years it
very well might have in the early years
of school you may have chosen this study
method and still pulled off a zandi's
but you're going to notice that as the
year as you get to your later years of
school the subjects are too difficult is
too much information and by trying this
later on in your school years you're
going to start to see a decline in your
grades
so now adjustments need to be made so
the brain is very forgetful and here's a
quick test now pretend today is that
Thursday you might be watching this
video on a Monday you might be watching
this video on a Friday but pretend it's
that Thursday what do you have for
dinner one day ago you can probably
still remember it's still fairly fresh
in your head but go back to days we just
for dinner two nights ago that
comes more difficult would you have for
dinner three days ago it's only been
three days you probably can't remember
what you have for dinner one week ago
and I hope you see my point the brain is
very forgetful if you don't stop and
think about things and refresh your
memory so not only is the brain
forgetful but you've also learned a
whole lot of information over the past
17 days you've learned 17 days of
biology but that's not all you've also
learned 17 days of of new math we've
also learned 17 days probably of a
foreign language 17 days of perhaps an
English literature class 17 days of
history so I hope you see my point if we
wait until the day before the test to
study you might remember some of the
more recent days but you're probably
going to struggle at some of the further
dates back in your unit and so now
you're trying to reteach yourself two
and a half weeks of information in one
night that's the problem
I want to combat okay before I go any
further here's a fun little test guess
the lowest test score between these four
units chapter 1 introduction to biology
chapter 4 photosynthesis cellular
respiration chapter 6 mitosis and
meiosis chapter 29 the nervous system
every year the lowest test average is
introduction to biology chapter 1 this
should be the easiest topic of the
school year and it's always my lowest
test of the year well why is that
because it's earlier in the school year
many students prepare for this test
using the poor habits that we've
discussed but as the school year goes on
they learn better habits and even though
the topics are much more challenging
their performance is greater so let's go
into that next so am I suggesting then
that students do this am I suggesting
students spend 2 hours a day studying
like they spend two hours at baseball
practice and two hours at Orchestra no
there's not enough hours in the day this
is not what I am suggesting well so what
am I suggesting I'm suggesting that you
create a study calendar where let's say
you spend 20 or 30 minutes devoted to
class a twenty or thirty minutes devoted
to class B on a Monday and then the next
day you spend twenty or thirty minutes
devoted to Class C twenty or thirty
minutes devoted to class B and you
repeat this pattern as the week goes on
obviously take Friday night off but then
you know Saturday afternoon get back to
it you know maybe take sunday off but
then Monday the following week get back
to it and you create this calendar this
plan where you're dividing up your time
and your resources and your efforts so
by keeping the material fresh in your
head you're more likely to remember so
how can you spend these twenty to thirty
minutes studying you know I love
analogies pretend your job is to build
this house well in order to build a
house need a whole bunch of tools so
start thinking what tools do you need a
hammer is one very important tool a saw
is another very important tool a drill
another very important tool a wrench
another very important tool in fact
you're going to need a whole bunch of
tools in order to build this house now
one tool alone you cannot build the
house but with the entire collection of
tools you can and here's my analogy well
what study tools do you use whenever I
asked young students this they almost
always tell me these two they will read
their class notes before a test and
they'll make flashcards now these are
good tools however they're just like a
hammer and a saw can you build an entire
house with only a hammer and a saw no
you need more tools
so I hope you see my point try new study
tools try online quizzes try outlining
passages from your reading material try
watching YouTube videos one day see your
teacher before or after school for help
you may be rewriting your class notes
forming study groups all of these tools
will help you do better just like you
need a lot of tools to build a house so
if we look at this study calendar notice
how we're using different tools every
couple days it shouldn't take any more
than 20 to 30 minutes to rewrite your
notes or 20 to 30 minutes to try an
online quiz or 20 to 30 minutes to
review flashcards this is a great idea
that you might want to try to divide up
your studies now there's one study tool
that I think is better than all the
other ones that I just mentioned so
which one is it
well let's look at this analogy which is
the better way to learn something
pretend that you're going to be awarded
$1,000,000 if you can pass a German
proficiency test now you're only going
to be given one month study so how you
choose a study is going to be really
important so study option a go down to a
local book store buy a how to speak
German audiobook and listen to that
morning noon and night for one month or
option B fly to Germany for a month come
back take the test which option will
teach you German better option B by far
option B and here's why well when you're
in Germany you're forced to speak the
German language listen to the German
language read the German language write
the German language and by accomplishing
all of these skills you are interacting
with the Germans in the German language
and this is why it's more effective our
brain learns better by incorporating all
of these skills well now can
you fly to a country called biology well
of course not but here is the next best
thing one of the best study methods I
can suggest is to form a study group
with you and a few of your classmates it
will simulate flying to Germany let me
explain here's you and classmate a B and
C you all met at the library you're
seated around the table if partner a
says something interesting what skill
are you performing well hopefully you
are listening to partner a if you want
to share your thoughts what's good
performing by you sharing your thoughts
you're probably speaking biology if
partner B says something interesting
what can you do to remember what was
said at a later date
you're probably writing biology if
partner seed points out something
interesting in a text book what skill
are you going to be performing well
you'll probably be reading biology and
because you're interacting you're
discussing main topics you're comparing
and contrasting different answers you're
defending your view from an opposing
view you are now interacting with
biology just like fly in the Germany to
try to understand and learn the German
language you know creating a new routine
is difficult a great example of that
happens every January come the New
Year's where people make a resolution to
join a gym and get in better shape and
so maybe the plan is work out two days
in a row Monday and Tuesday and then
take a day of rest and then two days in
a row Thursday and Friday they work out
and then they take a dare rest and week
one is going great and now week two
comes around you know they work out
maybe two days in a row but instead of
taking one day of rest
it stretches into three days of rest
instead of working out two days in a row
it's only one day in a row before the
day of rest come the third week the days
of rest are really taken over their
routine maybe they make the gym once
but then the days of rest become more
plentiful
Tim's around the world see this pattern
every January proving that a new routine
is difficult so please be supportive of
your student so parents guardians offer
some help be supportive your student
will likely need help as they adjust to
this new routine ways to be supportive
you can help organize study groups you
can offer your home you can offer to
drive your student to the low to the
gathering location you can perhaps
institute a positive reinforcement plan
where if your student meets the
agreed-upon criteria then there's some
sort of positive reinforcement for them
perhaps you can join in on the study
process now I'm not suggesting that you
join in the study group your student
would be mortified if you were there but
perhaps you can you know on another day
where it's just you and your student you
can offer to quiz your student and to
maybe check some of their work so these
are ways that you can be supportive and
I hope you found that this study
calendar to be helpful please place your
comments in the box below I'd love to
hear your feedback thanks for watching